Chris I want to start with you but
before we talk about the movie I want to
ask you about your folks I wanna ask
about your mom and dad and show how they
factored into this story yeah what they
meant to you about why the story had to
be told
woman my dad was a German Jewish refugee
he was born in Berlin in 1923 left the
country in 1933 eventually emigrated to
America and joined the US Army went into
the OSS which was the precursor to the
CIA and did undercover work because his
English his German was perfect and he
looked Aryan and he did various things
at the end of the war undercover and
afterwards he as a kind of a second job
he he wrote biographies of prominent
Nazi Party officials and I was his kind
of helper so I grew up with all of these
issues floating around my head and my
mom was an actor she was nominated for
the Academy Award for the Best
Supporting Actress Academy Award in 1959
for Imitation of Life which is in this
film it happens to be at the theater and
that theater is in the film
where the theater where they actually
went with the real wheat we shot at the
real theater where Klaus Eichmann and
Sylvia Hermann met the New York theater
and Olivas and - itis and imitation of
life was not playing that be too strange
artistic license but I thought the my
mom's role of and a girl passing as
white really suited this situation I'm
gonna ask you Brian about how this
script came your way who had written in
and what was it primarily interested in
at the first time that you came across
this story was I the first the first
time you came across this yeah sure a
young writer a young sort of unknown
writer out of the UK named Matt Orton
who's 26 and hadn't really written and
written a couple other scripts but had
certainly had nothing produced up until
now and Fred and I read it and
and flipped out for it both just sort of
the the level of historical fact we had
a long conversation with him about what
was true and untrue and how he had gone
to Israel and researched it for a number
of months and then MGM was reading it
sort of simultaneously to us and we all
collectively fell in love with it and
MGM made an offer immediately and we
were off to the races
how'd the casting come together guys
well honestly we went straight to Kris
and Kris said yes and then and then we
went out to Oscar so it was it's a weird
one because there's so many times when
there all these bumps in the road but
this was one of these things that
everybody that we talked to was
profoundly passionate about came on
pretty quickly too when you are starting
to look at the stories that are told
around us there are different people who
have written about their recollections
and some of those recollections are at
odds with each other so how do you
figure out what is the core of the truth
I mean this is not quite Rashomon but
people have different memories of
specific incidents so how do you figure
out what is the story and how truthful
you're gonna be to what you believe the
consensus of facts point toward I think
you we tried to be as accurate as
possible and we had various people
keeping us honest not the least an ex
Mossad agent called Avner Avraham who is
the kind of world expert on the mission
and who mounted the exhibition that's
currently during the world about
operation finale that being said people
remember things differently and if and
there are several memoirs which are
mutually contradictory unsurprisingly
each agent felt that he was the hero of
the mission
Peter Malkin was in many ways the most
interesting of these guys and reported
having had these kind of strange
intimate conversations with Eichmann in
the safehouse so that was kind of the
heart of I think Matt's script and I
think the most appealing thing
for Oscar to to perform every detail in
the movie has been vetted in one way or
another so we we extrapolated certain
things we just opposed things we move
things forward in time but it is an
incredibly well informed picture of of
what happened inevitably making a two
hour version of any series of events
amounts to a to taking artistic license
but we were pretty careful about about
what we put in on a production side when
you figure out that you want to and
should be shooting in Argentina what are
the obstacles to doing that and is it
worth noting that there probably still
some people in Argentina whose loyalties
are maybe leaning more toward Eichmann
than they are toward Israel and here in
the US to probably well we'll get to
that in a minute as I think many people
in this room probably can relate to
anytime you have a script that's set in
a foreign country there's someone who
holds the purse strings telling you to
shoot anywhere but that place so we were
we were told that Budapest would be a
great place to make this movie or
Vancouver and it just on paper never
makes sense to shoot with the story set
and as producers and filmmakers it is
always the best choice and we pretty
good at fighting that fight and to
everyone's credit MGM is not you know
most videos are not looking for period
spy dramas so they they were incredibly
emotionally invested in this store and
wanting to tell Italy and as soon as it
became our responsibility to make the
numbers work they supported that
decision 100% and I think you probably
felt in the movie even though there's a
lot of interior conversations that yet
that specificity of place and time is
reflected so powerfully and viscerally
in the movie and I think it just adds a
character to the film that's you know
unreplaceable Jason how much reference
is there for physical locations for what
the houses look like and maybe what
Oscar and Ben were able to use and
of how these people spoke and what they
sounded like how they behaved
I know Oskar used Peter Malkin's book
quite a bit as reference for his
character on the conversations Chris
spoke about our production designer did
an amazing job building the house on
Garibaldi Street and you know finding
all these other locations where her
location scouts were I mean amazing we
shot the movie and had it going up in
Bariloche we did all the Austria stuff
up there and we shot all throughout the
city what the house was hour and a half
outside or we had to schlep every day
for weeks yeah I mean there was every
reason kind of financially to build the
the interrogation room and parse the
safehouse in a studio but we found a
house that felt very much like what we
knew about the the original safehouse
and we figured out that we could still
shoot in sequence within that house so
that sometimes you know there were
lighting arrangements that were left in
place so that that big lights didn't
have to be humped up and down stairs but
but the crew had to move a lot of heavy
equipment up and down stairs in order to
shoot it in sequence oh I thought that
was worth doing I think also there's
some really creepy real things that
happen while we were shooting the night
of the capture that lightning and
thunder was actually happening at that
moment and it was it was very bizarre
night I mean watch all that Eichmann
himself said a couple of obviously very
contradictory things about himself and
about the role he played in the war
toward the end of the war Eichmann said
I'm quoting him now with leap laughing
into the grave because the feeling that
he had five million people on his
conscience would be for him a source of
extraordinary satisfaction and yet when
he was captured and when he was seeking
clemency he said there's a need to draw
a line between the leaders responsible
and the people like me
forced to serve as mere instruments in
the hands of the leader I was not a
responsible leader and as such do not
feel myself guilty yeah that's a lot to
play as an actor
so in your conversations with Ben what
were the things you kept coming back to
in terms of the honesty and deceit that
Eichmann told himself well I think we
had some important early conversations
in which we established that we both
felt that he should not be in any way a
stock villain or some kind of notion of
the embodiment of evil part of that was
deciding not to have him do an accent
which was actually true across the board
I just wanted people to speak the way
that they spoke I didn't want any scrim
between the audience and him and I think
that he felt that he would be a more
threatening figure if it weren't so easy
to place him on the shelf as a villain
that there would be moments in which you
might strangely be drawn to him or feel
sympathy for him and I think the scary
thing about Eichmann is that as well as
doing all the terrible things that he
did he loved his children he was a
family man and and I think that once if
you were able to recognize that about
him you can understand how it is
possible for people around us even for
ourselves to commit horrible crimes
under the right circumstances
Fred Jason Bryan Chris thank you so much
for coming and thank you guys for spend
your time with us